on the shore volunteers dogs
participants with an expression of
cautious anticipation six weeks ago I
think when we initially thought wouldn't
that be a crazy idea and here we are in
soundscape in general the idea is that
you hear spatialized audio that is you'd
hear it in your right ear or something's
off to your right your left ear
something's off to your left on the
water we're taking that idea in order
for you to go capture beacons the
primary goal today is to be safe and the
secondary goal is to have a lot of fun
Cindy and Mary had teammate approaching
the water kayaks on the lake in the
distance on the water's edge
Emily learning to paddle and the first
team is off sliding into the water like
a ticking sound that's sort of a benign
like clock ticking almost but it's kind
of a loafing rhythm reg paddling donning
a headset with an expression of intense
focus on his target and as you turn you
start to hear a pinging that's more of
like a positive sound when you're riding
or to your left ear and then when you
get it in the center you just move
directly toward it and try to keep it in
the center of your auditory field you
got it all right nice a selfie shot of
Nancy and a teammate John team fun in
the Sun Cindy
smiling and full of joy coming back to
shore
Wow how was the experience I don't think
I've experienced anything like this
before in this way I was very excited
about the soundscape product and use it
and this is a really fun use for it
every single team was successful in
their panel you guys crushed it you did
amazing I really appreciate the whole
soundscape team having all of us out
today I'm happy to be a part of a
movement and that is to help all of us
live more independently and full and
rich lives logo for outdoors for all
linked to Microsoft soundscape Microsoft
empowering everyone to achieve more